お前たち！ 男は、　化粧すると思うか？
俺は知ってるんだよ
今の時代はな？ 男でも化粧する。これはもう常識なんだ。
僕もね？  いつまでもこんな  スッピンでいる訳にもいかないんで、
今日は自分で、ﾁｮｯﾄ、メイクをしてみようと思います
恥ずかしながら 頑張って薬局でねぇ、 化粧品を 買ってきた訳ですよ。
化粧品を・・・これなんだろう？　コージー・スプリング・ハート・アイラッシュ
アイラッシュですね。  これはなんか、目の、目のつけま、つけま
肌に　ポン　ポン　ポン　とする、　ぽん！
ふんわり 溶け込む ね、ニューハーフ顏のチーク！
違う、  立体ハーフ顏のチーク。
リップ美容液。 さくらんぼ色の、リップ！
リキッド・アイライナー。
７色に 煌めく  ラブリーな パッチリ目のね、 アイカラー。
ファンデーション、 これはね、 ファンデーションです。
というわけで、 わたしの部屋の下に、 先輩と、 友達がいるんだけどぉ
あたしがね？  綺麗な お化粧をして 驚かせにくのぉ
やるぞ
俺はいつも  佐々木あさひ さん の動画見て、お化粧のね研究をしてるからね。
因みに ちょっと 眉毛が 無くなっちゃってさ
髭剃りで  ﾁｮｯﾄ眉毛を 整えようとしたら、全部無くなっちゃった。
じゃ、早速やって行こうと思います。
俺はもう、 あさひ さん の動画、　いつも見てるからね、　大体わかるんだよ
先ずは、ファンデーションです。これはねテッパンだよ。
指にね、 ちょっと取るくらいが 一番いいってね、 あさひさんが言ってた。
肌にこうね？部分的に、  こうつける。
で、肌になじませる
これはねぇ、大事、とても大事よ？
化粧、このねぇ、もうファンデーションから女は勝負決まるってワケよ。
これで肌の生地は完成よ?
チークなの、違う違うニューハーフ顏のチークを付けましょう
ブラシで適量を含ませ、手の甲で色の付き具合を・・・ブラシ持ってないわ
歯ブラシで代用しましょう
色んな色がある
歯ブラシで、、うっ！
あ、ヤバ ヤバいぞ、 これはヤバいぞ
こういう感じで  チークを  しっかり  肌になじませて  行きます。
いい感じだ
あ、 でも、 おお、 これは来てるんじゃね？
んふふふふふ
可愛い(笑)
多分、 あさひさんだと、 この場合は 多分先に、 アイライナー。 アイライナー付けます
アイライナー どこに使うか わかんない
あっ、 あっ、 あっ、 アイライナーって わかった、これか
ぴくっ、 てなるやつか・・・よし
あ、間違えた！ ﾁｮ、待って待って
これでしょ？
うん、 そう、  いい感じ、  いい感じ。　  これでいんじゃね？   これでもう、　アイライナーは   ﾊﾞｯﾁﾘ  だと思います。
これでもう  アイライナーは  ﾊﾞｯﾁﾘ  だと思います。
もう、訳わかんない。
取りあえず口紅だ！
唇塗りましょう
さくらんぼ色の口紅です
どうやって塗るﾝﾀﾞ…　えっ、なんか口紅もおかしくね？
っあっ！
クフ笑・・・
まじか？　いい感じだ・・・もう一息だ。　眉毛がねーわ！
ﾁｮｯﾄ、アイカラーで眉毛を描きましょう。
アイライナーの 茶色いのを  使って眉毛を 描きましょう
うん、完璧！
じゃ、このまま目まで行きましょう
目はチョット、 ラブリーな 感じに したいので、 ピンクで。
あさひさんの・・・・・あさひさんの・・・あさひさんの
どうかしら？
もうちょっと、 チークがね、 多分ね、 強くてもね、 あたし良いと思うワケよ
うん、眉毛もちゃんと生えたし
も、もー、もー息だと思います。
どうやって 付けつけまつげなん てするの？
取れた。　おかしくね？
これ、いいの？　あ！　キタ、キタ、来たんじゃね？
あ、これ来たわ。　あ、あ、出来た、出来た
ｱﾚ？、でも、目が、目がおかしい
何かおかしいよね、やっぱり・・・まあいいや
これで付け睫毛はバッチリです。
いかに目の周りをきれいに見せるか。これがま、勝負ね
鼻のラインをね？　こう、入れる事にで顔が小さく見えるって　あさひさんが言ってた。
ちょっと変になって来てるな
チークが強くなった気がするな
唇にﾁｮｯﾄ茶色を入れて、こう、チョコを食いかけてた、みたいな、お茶目な感じも入れてきたいすね
おかしくなった気がするけど、完成です
どうかしら？
早速、先輩と友達の所に行ってみましょう
気持ちワル